oh sausage
oh [ __ ] we're rolling
welcome back to tasty's making fake i'm
alvin and i make large versions of some
of america's most beloved foods and
today we are going to be making a huge
version of the classic mcdonald's
mcgriddle i actually grew up never
eating one of these i was given hash
browns and orange juice by my parents
because they were healthier they said
that's definitely not true you know how
much fat is in those things i'm going to
relive my childhood nostalgia or lack
thereof by making
a large mcgriddle enough said let's get
[Music]
as started been told a mcgriddle starts
with a pancake like bun so we're gonna
make giant pancake
this may or may not uh
be the same way that they do make it at
the golden arches if they do let me know
i'm actually curious on how they're made
milk
and i'm spilling good job dude flour
baking soda
sugar and salt
and
golden whisk for the golden arches
good one alvin
don't want too many lumps in here
[Music]
all right let's get in this butter
double wish double whisk
it's like rubbing your belly and patting
your head i can do that actually
[Music]
good job what if there's a like a life
scenario in which that'll actually come
in handy i don't know maybe like squid
game or something like that
batter is looking good nice and battered
and this
is going into quite a large pancake
it's over there see you guys
like 20 feet from here
so i forgot to add something the
mcgriddle apparently
has a lot of syrup infused into the bun
that's pretty
man i'll be just pouring like 30 dollars
into this bun right here i've been
informed that this batter
is the same amount of batter used to
make around 60 pancakes
and this is only one of the buns so this
uh this mcgriddle's gonna be
approximately 120 times the size of a
normal one
in here we have quite a large pan
pancake should go in a hot pan this is
been roughly preheated
yeah
there we go
nice nice sizzle that's good that's good
grandpa told me try not to waste so i
won't
do my best grandpa back in you go dude
this will cook
until it's ready
i'm gonna make a big sausage thing now
[Music]
what is
under this bowl you might ask well we
have approximately
20 pounds of ground pork this is
a lot of meat and we're gonna make the
sausage out of this and to do this we're
gonna need a lot of seasoning lots of
seasoning garlic and onion powder
ground sage
thyme
a lot of time
salt
pepper
and
brown sugar honestly i think sugar and
savory foods are underrated and often
missed but they can make the big
difference between what tastes really
good and what tastes just okay just like
salt in desserts is also
quite underrated this is probably also
why the mcgriddle tastes great because
there is syrup in the bun there's sugar
in the patty there's probably sugar in a
lot of other things as well so
ground pork the one we have has a good
amount of fat content and that's one of
the reasons why sausage tastes good but
this sausage is
as mixed as it can honestly it does
smell good
all right we gotta
get you into our big cake pan
do not handle your newborn like this
yeah definitely don't handle your
newborn like this
who needs rumble when you got this
fun fact i'm actually pretty good at
giving massages because growing up
my parents would always ask me to give
them a massage at the end of the day
because they were tired and over time i
got quite good at knowing how to massage
correctly some people think oh you just
no you can't do that you actually have
to go like this and you don't make your
fingers firm you have to let your
fingers
be loose
and a massage is more than just
doing this
you got gotta do it the right way
because if you hit the wrong spots it
hurts so i'm giving this sausage patty a
little bit of massage
all right
into the oven we go
somebody order a pizza
this is heavy oh what's up do a little
pancake
here you have a buddy to keep you
company in that oven oh man that's
looking good all right peace out have a
good time be friends
a mcgriddle has the signature fluffy egg
square and we are going to make the same
exact thing but big
so 24 eggs gonna get destroyed
[Music]
that was fun heavy cream
may get fluffy and salt
one more time into this machine of death
all right thank you honestly one of the
most underrated tools in the kitchen the
immersion blender solves a lot of
problems turns them into smooth
solutions
into a tray this is 24 eggs we're gonna
be making two of these because well this
is not making it average
gotta make it big
into some parchment to make my life
easier for the removal into the oven we
go yet again
so the fourth and final component that
we have for our mcgriddle today is the
giant cheese slice it could be easy to
throw cheese slices on top of the thing
and call it a day but this isn't you
know making it lazy
so we're gonna make our own version of
an american cheese slice and that starts
with gelatin
and
milk getting bloomed in here you might
recall this technique being used from
the previous season where we made a
giant krabby patty and if you did
you would be right 10 points to you
while the gelatin blooms we're gonna
heat up some milk and some butter
this is a nice glass
where'd you cut this glass this glass
may or may not disappear within the
course of the next three days some
butter
in goes the gelatin bloomed mixture
i believe i've seen this method used on
other websites and people that are
really good with food such as
serious eats j kenji lopez really cool
technique to make your own american
style cheese with other cheeses which
makes a lot of sense and i like burgers
so
if i wanted to make a fancy burger i'll
probably do this this is more cheddar
than i have in my bank account that's
okay it's we'll talk about that later
some salt
all right
i'm very prone to spilling so we're
gonna actually not um do something
stupid i'm gonna make the smart decision
oh
we're gonna no it's good i'll go the
other way as you can see i'm very prone
to spilling
[Music]
that's a sound i'll get in there and uh
scrape down the sides real quick oh it's
looking nice you guys see that
i gotta scrape down the side that is
satisfying
wow
now
gotta get it
on here
look at that
that's some thick smooth cheese
you guys ever heard of velveeta
or the nacho cheese you get at the
bowling alley with your chips those are
good
spread this guy oh
[Music]
that's nice oh that's nice i like that a
lot oh so smooth damn
it's like frosting a cake but there's no
cake
the frosting is cheese
so it's actually not like frosting a
cake at all it's just really satisfying
to do
it's also kind of like a race against
time because you gotta get it before the
cheese starts to set but it's feeling
pretty good looking really good
all right
i'm gonna call it
this
is gonna be a large cheese slice
and this
is going in to the fridge
[Music]
i think it's time we can build
this giant
mcgriddle we got
a bun
we got
a patty
and we have
two sheets of egg
two sheets of cheese
within a little alley from the culinary
team
i think it's time we build
see what this bun looks like
wait no it's gonna flip and it's gonna
hit me in the face here we go
hold on my brain can't work right now
oh that's a nice one look at that it's
all shiny and nice
okay so this will be our top bun
[Music]
all right
oh my crackage that's all good so we
gotta get our cheese slices out let's
give a little trim first
[Music]
let's get this guy on there
we go
now that's a cheese slice
okay
this is a heat gun it helps melt things
on this show
oh that's hot
we'll be right back
it's getting a little melty
does smell good i'm also counting on the
heat from this patty to continue melting
it so
here we go
big boy time for the eggs
whoa
that's one
this
is two
oh man
that's pretty cool
all right
and the final
shiny top bun
i got it yeah this is sturdy
nice
that's a mcgriddle
well mcdonald's seems to have their
signature on every single mcgriddle well
you know i like to put my name on things
so i'm gonna see if we can dot in a
little
a little a you can get
a nice
pattern
going look at that
that's an a or that's that's a line
oh this is going to be delicious look i
want to say we're putting in this thing
nobody tell my doctor
just kidding i'm going to see the video
oh you can see it in the top down let's
go oh this is not a mcgriddle this is a
griddle
because there's a a on it
this
is a normal mcgriddle
this
is
a griddle as you can see there's quite a
big size difference okay let's bisect
this guy and see what we got here we go
straight down the middle
oh heck yeah pardon me while i don my
protective measures and here we go
[Music]
that is a cross section a double egg
layer a nicely cooked sausage still
juicy and the cheese
[Music]
that's pretty cool
all right i'll take a
honorary wedge
one slice is bigger than the whole thing
god
cheers
gonna have to eat this in like three
bites to get all the flavor
[Music]
i think the key to this whole thing
is the syrup the syrup is what makes it
taste and smell like what i think this
tastes like wait i haven't had this one
hold on
[Music]
it's like the same thing but big
also take a little wedge of this
let's see
[Music]
this tastes so similar
do the same thing that's really cool
good job
alvin
well that was quite fun it's a good
thing that i do like eating what i make
because it seems like i'll be having
lunch breakfast and dinner for quite
a long time i give you all the sugar
getting to my uh to my blood vessels and
i haven't had this much sugar in quite a
while so i'm gonna go and maybe run it
off i'll see you guys in the next
episode
peace
[Music]
you